I grew up in, like,
suburban Rancho Cucamonga.
It was a lot of being bored
and figuring out what to do with myself.
I learned to juggle
knives, I was in a band,
I did puppetry, I played baseball.
My favorite movies were
'The Shawshank Redemption'
and 'About a Boy' and 'Forrest Gump'.
For a lot of executives,
in the first 30 seconds,
they think I'm gonna talk with an accent
or they think I'm not gonna
know about normal things
like, there's this little
sparkle of amusement.
"Different than what I thought
a regular Muslim person would be like".
When I got into UCLA Film School,
I was so incredibly excited,
but I didn't have any connections.
I was just like, well, I'm gonna
try it and see how it goes.
People are always
telling these sob stories
about immigrants, things
like 'The Namesake',
but the stories I grew up
hearing were hilarious.
So, I was like, I wanted
to do something with that.
[Movie Clip]: "Listen to me, Sami."
"To be a great tiger hunter,"
"you must become the tiger."
'The Tiger Hunter' is
my first feature film
about a young man who comes from India
on this big quest for success in America,
and it was all kind of based on truth.
I interviewed my dad,
I interviewed my mom,
I interviewed the aunties
and uncles in the community.
It's called 'The Tiger Hunter'
because my grandfather was a tiger hunter.
He has the exact same mustache.
It was all kind of based on truth.
My dad, when he came into this country,
all of his roommates
only had one epic suit.
They'd be like, sitting in
their underwear at home,
scheduling their interviews around
the availability of the suit.
[Movie Clip]: "Ketchup!"
"Well, I was hungry."
I tried so many strategies
to raise money for my movie.
It was like pulling teeth.
First, I tried South Asian doctors.
And then, film school people were like,
"Okay, try dentists, because
dentists have doctor"
"in their title and they
wanna have that respect"
"like doctors have, but they don't".
I sent thousands of those e-mails.
They're cold e-mails.
They'd be like, "Hey,
I'm doing this movie."
"I don't know if you'll get
your money back or not,"
"but you and I could enter
the industry together."
"How about that?"
And then, when my executive
producer called and said,
"Alright, I'm in for X amount of money",
I think I was just jumping
up around my house.
I ran into my parents' room and of course,
their response was like,
"Don't count it until it's in the bank".
I thought it was gonna be a little movie
and it suddenly became a very big movie.
My sister-in-law, she's like, "Oh my god,"
"you have Danny Pudi
and all these people",
and then Kevin Pollak was on board,
then Napoleon Dynamite, Jon Heder.
I was like, "Okay, now I'm
getting a little nervous".
We had this huge crew,
everyone's running around
with their walkie-talkies,
and you look out
and you're like, "This is my set".
Like, "I'm making a feature film",
and there is no feeling like that
that I think I've had, ever.
The cool thing that ended up happening
is that our crew became
very, very diverse.
We had black people, we had
Asian people, we had women,
we had a Sikh guy, we had Hindu guys,
we had Pahari people.
We came in out in 50-some
theaters across the country.
Awesome reviews in things
like The New York Times.
We would be playing in
the middle of Virginia
and it was just such an amazing thing
to see them laughing along
at the exact same parts
that, like, some Indian uncle
would be laughing along with.
I wanna do something good in the world
and that's sort of why
I chose this profession.
People don't usually think
this profession is for that,
but it totally can be.
Like, it can be a total game-changer.
And now there's people helping me,
people with suits who get things done.
I got attached to direct
this major Disney feature.
There's less executives
who, when I walk in,
have that 30-second window
where they're surprised
by everything I say that
is not with an accent.
And that is progress.
[Clip]: (audience cheers)